news for members of parliament's econ
committee of another quarter of super
modest growth in europe 0.2
but it's the fourth in a row prompting
mario draghi the head of the european
central bank to urge consolidation of
finances with a familiar message
attached the idea of spending out of the
crisis
is not
a viable one
it's a mixture of things lower taxes
lower unproductive expenditure
but most importantly is structural
reforms and what of the apparent rumors
suggesting he'd be leaving i'll stay at
the ecb
and all the rumors to the contrary are
unfounded
so there's a new commission president
but there are still four months before
the deadline for his new team of
commissioners to be in place meantime
four serving commissioners now meps need
replacing for the transition budget
commissioner janos lewandowski by fellow
poll yatzek dominic justice commissioner
viviane redding by fellow luxembourger
martine reicherts antonio tajani
industry commissioner by italian nelly
faroci and commissioner for economic and
monetary affairs ali rain by fellow finn
yirky kartinen
the european commission is withdrawing a
bill designed to harmonize maternity
rights for employees agreed by
parliament in 2010 but which has been
blocked ever since by disputes between
member states the maternity leave
directive would among other measures
have made 20 weeks leave mandatory
across the eu i welcome the decision and
it is respecting that family life is not
something that someone can decide and
micromanage from brussels it's something
that is too much serious
to be you know revoked just because of
an administrative procedure with the
withdrawal of this file
we are supporting the pay gap women's
groups hope the new commission president
jean-claude juncker will resurrect the
bill